hi Megan how are you hi Dave I'm doing
well in yourself better than I deserve
what's up listen and I went through SPU
this past fall for the first time and we
were in the unique position that when we
started as to you we were already on
baby step three also and we completed
baby step three while we were in class
and now we're on four five six sure and
I'm I'm having a little bit of trouble I
want to be very cause l intense and just
throw stuff at the mortgage as fast as
possible but I know that we have like
some big purchases coming in the next
couple of years that we need to save for
and I guess I'm just having trouble
emotionally and mentally finding the
balance between being gizelle and tents
especially since I didn't get that in
baby set to with balancing the need to
say for some of these large purchases
it's a great question well what we've
seen people do and be the most
successful at is you've got to be
gizelle intense gizelle intense is when
you're in baby steps one through three
and that means no life all you're doing
is concentrating on getting out of debt
and building that emergency fund as fast
as possible beans and rice rice and
beans no vacation no eating out no life
complete focus completely as we say in
the South lay your ears back and get
into it right go go for it that's like a
horse and a horse race they lay their
ears back and they're going for it
that's gizelle intense running as if
your life depends on it when you bust
through baby step three we suggest at
that point letting your foot off the gas
on the Gazelle intensity so I wouldn't
apply what we call gazelle intensity
extreme levels of sacrifice to baby
steps four five and six the four five
and six is the ongoing portion of your
life for the next many years until your
house is paid off so four is fifteen
percent of your income going into
retirement while you're doing something
towards your kids college depending on
where they are as to what you do and
then the rest is going towards paying
off the house of what you can squeeze
out of your budget but this is where you
now you go back on vacation now you
allow yourself to go out to eat a little
bit now you are maybe upgrade the couch
and pay cash for it or upgrade the car
and pay cash for it and you save up to
the
that each time you do that of course it
does slow down how fast you pay off your
home but because you entered a Financial
Peace University already in baby step 3
you had a very short gazelle intensity
experience and you don't need to feel
guilty for that ok I guess part of me
really wants to because it was our only
debt so it's ok to do yeah we've let off
the gas a little bit we do try to go out
to eat maybe twice a month do it good
and and one of these others one of these
purchases vacation but a staycation this
year okay what are the purchases looming
in the distance probably within the next
year or two the washer and dryer will
need to be replaced they're kind of on
their last legs and we're looking to
grow our family so we'd like to upgrade
from one of our little four-door cars to
a minivan what's my hard
what's your household income my husband
makes about one 105 a year okay you'll
be able to do both of those things and
you just concentrate on those and
obviously those are two things that are
very reasonable and you need to do it
and what's that going to mean
mathematically it means you put a little
less on the mortgage yes but what I
suggest you pay down your mortgage
faster and stay in a dinky car when your
family has outgrown your car and you and
you make one hundred five thousand and
you're debt-free no I wouldn't do that
would I suggest that you you know never
go out to eat while you pay on your
house for the next six years no I'm not
suggesting that it's never what we've
taught and so you know yeah just let
your foot off the accelerator plan those
purchases out and then once you knock
you say okay we need a van fund and it's
not you know set the goal how much do we
want to put in the van fund and then you
know when you got that knocked out then
everything else goes back to the
mortgage right or you do the vacation or
whatever and then you everything else
goes back towards the mortgage that the
trick here is just to be intentional to
do this stuff on purpose what happens is
is that people stay in a 30-year
mortgage for thirty years and then they
refinance it into it for another ten and
what you're never going to do that
because you're ruined you've been
through the Financial Peace University
you've changed the way you look at money
forever
what weird yeah you're officially weird
so you're going to be fine give yourself
permission to wiggle a little here
wiggle room okay thank you thanks for
the call you know why most people don't
win they don't bother you have to bother
it to be intentional never again as
American Express gonna call my house and
ask my wife why she would stay with a
man that won't pay his bills